im rahmen von erfolgreich österreich
besuchten der bundesminister für
landesverteidigung und sport magister
gerald klug und die bundesministerin für
inneres magister johanna mikl leitner am
9 april 2014 das burgenland in neutal
bezirk oberpullendorf informierten sich
die minister im beisein des
landeshauptmannes hans niessl über die
kampagne für mehr bewegung 60 40 man
will diesen wert umkehren so dass nicht
nur 40 prozent der bevölkerung sportlich
aktiv werden sondern mindestens 60
in güssing wurde europas modernste
kaserne besucht dabei werden die
gemeinsamen anstrengungen für mehr
sicherheit für die bevölkerung erläutert
hier werden die rekruten bereits nach
dem neuen modularen system ausgebildet
anlässlich einer video-konferenz mit dem
centre of excellence der cyber security
challenges an der fachhochschule
hagenberg wurden die teilnehmer
einblicke in ihre tätigkeit in
schachendorf wurde den ministern
effiziente schwerverkehrskontrolle
vorgeführt die polizisten und
polizistinnen kontrollieren unter
anderem die zulässigen gewicht der
fahrzeuge und die einhaltung der lenk-
und ruhezeiten
flexibel einsetzbare mobile büros und
prüfeinrichtungen unterstützen die
arbeit der polizei beim besuch des
bezirkspolizeikommandos und der
polizeiinspektion oberwart werden zahlen
präsentiert die untermauern dass das
burgenland das sicherste bundesland
österreichs ist